what do you
is the connection between free will and
consciousness and is free will and
illusion or not
good question so
i think we need to be a lot more
agnostic
about free will than than about
consciousness because
i don't think we have the kind of
certainty
of the existence of free will that we do
have in the consciousness case it could
turn out that free will is an illusion
it could be it feels as though we're
free when we're really not
whereas i mean i think the idea
that nobody really really feels pain
that we think we feel pain but that's a
lot harder to make sense of
however what i what i do feel strongly
about is i i don't think there are any
good either scientific or philosophical
arguments against the existence of free
will and i mean
strong free will and what philosophers
call libertarian free will in the sense
that some of our decisions are uncaused
so i very much do disagree with someone
like sam harris who thinks there's this
overwhelming case i i just think
it's non-existent i think there's
ultimately it's ultimately an empirical
question
but
as we've already discussed i just don't
think we know enough about the brain
to
establish
one way or the other um at the moment
but we can build up intuitions first of
all as a fan of sam harris as a fan of
yours i would love to just listen yeah
well thinking about termina so so one
thing would be beautiful to watch here's
my prediction what happens with you and
sam harris you talked for four hours
uh
and sam introduced that episode by
saying it was ultimately not as fruitful
as i thought because here's what's gonna
happen you guys are gonna get stuck for
the first three hours talking about um
one of the terms and what they mean
it's sam is so good at this i think it's
really important but you know sometimes
he gets stuck like
what does he say put a pin in that
he he really gets
stuck on the terminologies
which
rightfully you have to get right in
order to really understand what we're
talking about but sometimes you can get
stuck with them for the entire
conversation it's a fascinating dance
the one we spoke to in philosophy
if you can't if you don't get the terms
precise
you can't
really
be having the same conversation but at
the same time
it could it could be argued that it's
impossible to get
terms perfectly precise and
perfectly formalized so then you're also
not not going to get anywhere in the
conversation so um that's a it's a funny
dance where you have to be both rigorous
and everyone's neurologists let go and
then go and go back to being rigorous
yeah and formal and then and then every
once in a while let go it's the
difference between mathematics
the maths
and the uh
um poetry anyway um yeah i'm a big fan
of sam harrison i think and i think you
know i think we're um we're on the same
page in in terms of consciousness i
think um pretty much i mean i'm not
saying he's a pand psychist but in our
understanding of the hard problem
um
but yeah i i think maybe
we could talk about free will without
being too dragged down in the
terminology i don't know you said we
need to be open-minded but you could
still have intuitions about
so uh
sam
harris has a pretty sort of uh
counter-intuitive
and for some reason it gets people
really riled up uh view of free will
that it's an illusion
um
or or it's not even an illusion like uh
it's it's not that the experience of
free will is an illusion
is he argues that we don't even
experience
any like there's
to say that we even have the experience
is incorrect
that there's not even an experience of
free will
it's pretty interesting that that that
claim and it feels like you can build up
intuitions about what is
right and not you know there's been some
kind of neuroscience there's been some
cognitive science and
psychology experiments to sort of
see you know
what is the timing and the origin of the
desire to make an action and when that
action is actually performed and how you
interpret that action being performed
how you remember that action like all
the stories we tell ourselves all the
neurochemicals involved in making a
thing happen all what's the timing
and how does that connect with us
feeling like we decided to do something
then of course there's a more
philosophical discussion about
is there room
in a material view of the world
for an entity that somehow disturbs the
determinism of physics
yeah
and uh yeah those are all very precise
it's nice it feels like free will
is more amenable to like a physics
mechanistic type of thinking than his
consciousness
to to really get to the bottom of it
feels like if it was a race if we're at
a bar and we're betting money
it feels like we'll get to the bottom of
free will
faster than we will to the bottom of
consciousness yeah that's interesting
yeah and thought about the comparison
yeah so they're different arguments here
i mean
so what one argument i've heard sam
harris give that's pretty common in
philosophy
is this sort of thought that does
we can't make sense of a middle way
between
a choice being determined by prior
causes
and it just being
totally random and senseless like the
random decay of radioactive isotope or
something
so i think there was a good answer to
that by uh the philosopher jonathan lowe
who's not necessarily very well known
outside academic philosophy but hugely
influential
figure i think one of the best
philosophers of recent times he suddenly
died of
cancer a few years ago actually spent
almost all of his career at durham
university which where i am so
it was one reason it was a great honor
to get to get a job there but anyway his
answer to that was
what makes the difference between a free
action
and a totally senseless one senseless
random event
is that free choice involves
responsiveness to reasons
um so again we've talked about this
earlier
if i'm deciding whether to take a job in
the u.s or to stay in the uk i weigh up
considerations you know different stand
standards of life maybe or being close
to family or
cultural difference i'll weigh them up
and
i you know edge towards
a decision so
so i think that is sufficient to
distinguish it
um you know
we're hypothetically supposing trying to
make sense of this idea not saying it's
real but that could be
enough to distinguish it from a
senseless site it's not a senseless
random occurrence because the free
decision involved
responsiveness to reasons
um so i think that just answers the that
particular philosophical objection so
what what is the middle way between
determined by prior causes and totally
random well there's an action a choice
that's not determined by prior causes
but it's not just random because it it
did the decision essentially involved
responsiveness to reasons
so that's the answer to that and i think
actually that kind of thought also i
think you were hinting at
the famous liberty experiments where he
got his subjects
to perform some kind of random action of
pressing a button and then note the time
they decided to press it quote unquote
and then he's scanning the brains and
he claims
to have found that you know about half a
second before they consciously decided
to press the button
the brain is
getting ready to perform that action so
he claimed that about half a second
before the person has consciously
decided to press the button the brain
has already started the activity that's
going to lead to the action
um and then later people have um
claimed that there's a difference of
maybe seven to ten seconds i mean there
are all sorts of issues with these
experiments
but one is that
as far as i'm aware
all of the quote-unquote choices they've
focused on are just these totally random
senseless actions like just pressing a
button for no reason and i think the
kind of free will we're interested in
is free choice that involves
responsiveness to reasons weighing up
considerations and and those kind of
free decisions might not happen like at
an
identifiable instant you might when
you're weighing it up should i get
married should i you know you
you might edge slowly towards one side
or the other
and so it could it could be that
maybe the limit i think there are other
problems with the lipid stuff but maybe
they show that we can't
freely choose to do something totally
senseless whatever that would mean
um
but but that doesn't show we can't
freely
um in this strong libertarian sense
respond to considerations of reason and
value um
to be fair it would be difficult to see
what kind of experiment we could set up
to uh
test that but just because
we can't yet set up that kind of
experiment we shouldn't you know pretend
we know more than we do so yeah so for
those reasons i don't i i and well the
third consideration you raise is
different again this is the
debate i have with sean carroll
would this conflict with physics
i just think we don't know enough about
the brain to know whether there are
causal dynamics in the brain that are
not reducible to underlying
chemistry and physics and
so so then sean carroll says well that
would mean
our physics is wrong so he focuses on
the core theory which is the name for
standard model of particle physics plus
um
the weak limit of general relativity so
you know we can't totally bring
quantum mechanics and relativity
together
but actually that
the circumstances in which we can't
bring them together are just in
situations of very high gravity for
example when you're about to go into a
black hole or something actually in
terrestrial
circumstances we can bring them together
in in the core theory and then sean
wants to say well we can be very
confident that core theory is correct
and so
um
if there were libertarian free will in
the brain the core theory would be wrong
and okay this i mean this is something
i'm i'm
i'm not sure about and i'm i'm still
thinking about and i'm having i'm
learning from my discussion with sean
but i'm still not totally clear why
it could be suppose we did discover
strong emergence in the brain whether
it's free will or something else
perhaps what we would say is not that
the core theory is wrong but we'd say
uh the core theory is
correct in its own terms namely
capturing the causal capacities of
particles and fields
but then it's a further assumption
whether they're the only things that are
running the show maybe there are also
fundamental causal capacities associated
with
systems
and then if we discover this strong
emergence then when we work out what
happens in the brain we have to look to
the core theory the causal capacities of
particles and fields
and we have to look to what we know
about these strongly emergent causal
capacities of systems and maybe they
co-determine what happens in the system
um
so i don't know whether that makes sense
or not but i mean the more important
point i mean that's in a way a kind of
branding point how we brand this the
more important point is we just don't
know enough about the workings of the
brain to know whether there are
uh im strongly emerging causal dynamics
whether or not
that would mean we have to modify
physics or maybe just we think physics
is not
the total story what's running the show
but we just
if it turned out
empirically that everything's reducible
to underlying physics and chemistry sure
i would drop
any commitment to free libertarian free
will in a in a heartbeat it's an
empirical question maybe that's why as
you say it in principle is easier to get
a grip on but we're a million miles away
from being at that stage well i don't
know for a million miles i hope we're
not because one of the ways i think to
get to it
is by engineering systems so yeah my
hope is to understand intelligence by
building intelligent systems to
understand consciousness
by
building systems that
let's say the easy thing which is not
the easy thing but the first thing which
is to try to uh
create the illusion of consciousness
uh through that process i think you
start to understand much more about
consciousness about intelligence and
then the same with free will i think
those are all tied very closely together
as at least from our narrow human
perspective and we try to engineer
systems that interact deeply with humans
that form friends with humans that
humans fall in love with and they fall
in love with humans
then you start to
have to
try to deeply understand ourselves uh to
try to deeply understand
what is intelligence in the human mind
what is consciousness what is free will
you